hors effet avec le petit ami de jean
delà des genres à chier j'ai jamais vu
ces images
regardez à la non c'est pas expliquent
ces fraudes tu prends tes maire décline
tueur mais constituent des gages
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alain
[Applaudissements]
là
c'est tout un studio là
l'actice arriver aux banques sur la tête
c'est qu'ils avaient ramené ce bordel
ambiant
[Applaudissements]
en plateau mais à moïse et n'hésite pas
et d'une phrase qui est un classique qui
va rester dans le dans le cinéma
français grave et je rachid et rentrent
avec le plein comme ça tu dis ok on
arrête j'ai fait un couscous al arabia
tatiana ça n'existait pas et la vente
est ça le bouscat la non non non non il
ya un deuxième extrait un deuxième
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'annuler s'il vous plaît à chaque dose
d'amour
[Musique]